so negotiators from Iran and the six big
world powers have just emerged from
months of negotiations in Austria and
Switzerland to announce that believe it
or not they have an Iran nuclear deal
every pathway to a nuclear weapon is cut
off but what does that actually mean how
does all that actually work well this
gets technical really fast but it helps
if you go through and look at some of
the most important issues one of the big
ones is uranium that's the stuff dig it
out of the ground use it for nuclear
fuel for power plant or even for a bomb
the deal requires Iran to give up 97% of
its enriched uranium almost all of it
down to just a 300 kilogram stockpile
not very much uranium comes in different
levels of enrichment this restriction is
really severe Iran is only allowed to
have its uranium up to three point six
seven percent enrichment and to give you
a sense of what that means medical
research grade uranium is enriched to 20
percent and weapons-grade uranium is
enriched to 90 percent so Iran's uranium
is going to be way down at three point
six seven percent very safe and energy
grade and not something that is anywhere
near what can be used for a nuclear
weapon Iran is going to give up most of
its centrifuges it's going to go from
20,000 centrifuges to just 5,000 that
are spinning fissile material plus
another 1,000 that it can use for
research and development but can't use
fissile material and if Iran decided one
day you know what we don't like this
deal any more we're going to build a
bomb it would take it a really long time
to do it and that gets to another really
important issue and that's inspections
inspections and monitoring or how we
make sure that Iran is sticking to their
end of the deal and that they're not
cheating the inspections that the u.s.
got out of this deal are frankly just
astonishing a one arms control analyst
said he thought there was quote almost a
100% chance that if Iran cheated it
would be caught by these inspections
that's
good they are so what is a Ron get for
accepting all of this Witter Ron gets is
relief from the economic sanctions that
have been just crippling its economy but
what these sanctions do is they cut off
a rounds economy from the outside world
they cut it off from international
banking international finance these have
been just devastating Iran's economy
they are really desperate to get out
from under these and this is a big deal
not just for around the state but for
the 77 million people of Iran who to big
middle class and they've been suffering
under economic sanctions for too long
they will finally get to have a chance
at having a real economy hopefully very
soon after this